Here we are inside the MATLAB desktop environment.
I have set the working directory to the folder
that contains those holiday snaps.
So what we are going to do is load the image
we were just looking at into the MATLAB workspace.
I need to put that data into a workspace variable
called im. That is kind of my personal short
hand for image. We use the iread function.
Short for image read. And we put in the rather
cryptic name of the file that contains the
image. And we therefore load the picture into
this workspace variable called im. Another
toolbox function allows us to display a variable
as an image.
And here we can see it; here we can see the
crocodile displayed from inside the MATLAB
environment. The image file contains not just
the pixel information that we are looking
at here; it also contains what we call the
metadata. So let’s go back and see if we
can find the metadata. We will close that
image and we will modify our reading command
so that it returns two output variables.
The pixel data in the variable im and the
metadata into another variable called meta.
There we go. And display that variable called
meta. And we can see interesting information
here about the image, we can see the date
that it was taken, we can see that it was
taken with a Panasonic camera and we can see
the model of the camera. There is even more
detail information in this sub-structure.
And here we can see the exposure time and
the F number of the camera when I took that
particular picture and we can see that the
flash didn’t fire and lots of other information
as well.
But we are getting ahead of ourselves, we
have been dealing with a colour image and
colour is a topic that we are not going to
visit for another couple of weeks. So let’s
start with something a little bit simpler.
We are going to look at what some people call
a black and white image, but what is more
correctly known as a greyscale image. So what
I am going to do here is to clear all the
variables in the workspace, I am going to
clear the console. And I am going to load
a new image and this is an image that is shipped
with the software, it is an image of a street
in Paris and its file has got an extension
of PNG which stands for portable network graphic.
It’s just another type of image file format.
Load that into the workspace into the variable
im. Now we can see over here the information
about the variable. It says that it is 851
rows by 1280 columns. MATLAB is considering
this as a matrix. There is a few interesting
things about this matrix. MATLAB provides
a facility to examine the elements of a matrix.
We do that by right clicking on the variable,
and let’s maximise the view.
And here we can see a small, sub-section of
all the numbers that are within this very,
very large matrix. It is a spreadsheet style
display, it’s got scroll bars and we can
roll down and see lots and lots of numbers.
And you will see they’re all integer numbers.
You will see that there are no negative ones
and you will also notice that there are none
bigger then 255.
Another thing to notice is that this variable
has got a type and that type is uint8 and
that is short hand or code for unsigned integer
eight bits. So all the numbers in this variable
im are eight bit unsigned integers, which
means the smallest value they could have is
0 and the greatest value that they can have
is 255.
The MATLAB variable im contains a lot of numbers,
but they originated from an image so the numerical
information within that variable represents
visual information. So let’s display it
as an image rather then display it as numbers
and we use the function we used earlier, the
idisp function. Pass in the image. And here
we see a picture of a Parisian street.
Now what we can do is we can examine the various
pixels that comprise this image. So let’s
have a look at a pixel over here and if I
click on that, it displays three pieces of
information. The first piece of information
is the coordinate of this particular pixel
and the coordinate is a 105—that is the
horizontal coordinate—and 87, which is the
vertical coordinate. Now the image processing
the convention is that the horizontal coordinate,
I refer to that generally as the variable
u, increases from left to right and the vertical
coordinate which I generally refer to as v
increases from the top to the bottom. The
other piece of information that is displayed
here is what is called the greyscale value.
That is the numeric value of the pixel at
that particular coordinate and in this case
it has a value of a 194.
And we said that the pixel values can vary
between 0 and 255. Convention is that a low
number is dark and a high number is bright.
255 being the largest value corresponds to
bright white; 0, the smallest value, corresponds
to the darkest dark. This particular value—a
194—is fairly bright. If I click a value
in this dark doorway we see it has got a value
only of 12. Look down on the shadow of the
street, we see it has got a value of 66. So
the pixel values are reflecting the intensity
of light at this particular point in the scene.
We can also get access to this pixel value
by addressing the element within the matrix
directly. The matrix is the workspace variable
im and we need to provide first of all the
row coordinate, which is 653, and we need
to provide the column coordinate, which is
562. We access that element of the matrix
and we see the grayscale value of 66. Now
notice what has happened here is that the
indices have been reversed. When we index
into a matrix we provide the row coordinate
first then the column coordinate. Typically,
when we refer to the coordinate in the image
itself, we write the horizontal coordinate
first and then the vertical coordinate.